après les deux chefs de la coalition
gouvernementale venus tour à tour
s'expliquer ici sur leurs projets voici
que sun ce soir l'heure de vérité de
l'opposition au 63e jour de l'alu
stature nous recevons en effet le chef
du parti qui a été battu le 16 mars
dernier mais qui reste le parti le plus
puissant de france
numériquement parlant je veux parler du
parti socialiste monsieur jospin vous
avez écrit récemment dans le monde
le ps est la grande force d'opposition à
la politique actuelle mais il est et
doit être aussi la grande force de
proposition alors opposition
propositions ce sont là les les deux
volets principaux de notre émission de
ce soir quel bilan faites vous des
soixante trois premiers jours du
gouvernement chirac
comment comptez vous y prendre comptez
vous vous y prendre pour contrarier ses
projets et vous même les socialistes que
feriez vous si vous reveniez au pouvoir
alors on voit bien ce que pèse le ps qui
a recueilli aux dernières élections
les voix de près d'un français sur trois
mais on ne voit pas toujours très
clairement ce qu'il veut ce qu'il
propose
et comment il compte attirer vers lui
les talents qui existent dans tous les
domaines pour reprendre une de vos
formules dans précisément l'article du
monde
pour les socialistes le mois qui s'ouvre
sera celui de la réflexion sur la
modernisation de leur parti à 6 en avez
vous décidé
monsieur le premier secrétaire alors
vous le dirai pourquoi vous voulez
transformer le ps et jusqu'à quel point
alors conformément à nos habitudes dix
minutes avant l'émission la sofres a
établi par tes les sondages le palmarès
des curiosités et des attentes des
français qui nous regardent ce soir
alors voici les thèmes qu'ils
souhaiteraient pouvoir aborder en
priorité la situation actuelle de
monsieur mitterrand 47% vos critiques
envers le gouvernement 41%
ensuite en troisième position tf1 la
privatisation de tf1 et la réforme de
l'audience
visuel puis dans l'ordre quatrième votre
jugement sur les mesures de sécurité
prises récemment par le gouvernement
cinquième position votre opinion sur le
fonctionnement de la cohabitation est en
6 les propositions du ps en matière
économique a bien sûr de victoire de
retour au pouvoir de votre parti un jour
en septième position la préparation
d'élections présidentielles et enfin en
dernière position
la modernisation du ps qui ne retient
que 11% des avis des personnes que nous
avons interrogées alors avant de vous
laisser face alain duhamel à jean marie
colombani chef du service politique du
monde et albert du roy
une première question qui vous est posée
par les téléspectateurs et qui va être
formulée en leur nom par jean-loup de
scène avoue svt lionel jospin bonsoir
les questions qui vous sont posées ici
ce soir svp montrait d'abord au bilan
des cinq années est socialiste ensuite à
votre opposition systématique à la
privatisation de tf1 mais beaucoup
d'interrogations au trait à la
cohabitation par exemple que
penseriez-vous du président de gauche
si françois mitterrand signer finalement
la promulgation du texte autorisant la
suppression de l'autorisation
administrative de licenciement
le président de la république est obligé
de signer ce texte
il pourrait éventuellement demander une
deuxième lecture cela fait partie de ses
pouvoirs
mais il ne s'agit pas là d'une
ordonnance il s'agirait il s'agit d'un
projet de loi discuté
d'ailleurs ce soir encore à l'assemblée
nationale et si ce texte de loi à une
majorité le président de la république
est obligé de le promulguer dans les
quinze jours
c'est donc pas un problème de conscience
ni même un problème de choix politique
c'est l'obligation qui lui est faite
en tant que président par nos textes
vous irez l'assemblée nationale
tout à l'heure on se retrouve ici je
crois que nous en sommes à l'article 1
et personnellement si il est encore
temps j'ai bien envie d'aller ce soir à
l'assemblée nationale participer à cette
discussion peut être même y intervenir
parce que je pense qu'il s'agit de
quelque chose de très important est
peut-être en parlons nous ce soir dans
cette émission d'accord alors pour un
quart d'heure alain duhamel
on sort monsieur le premier secrétaire
bonsoir
est ce que vous considérez que jacques
lang est un homme politique sérieux à
priori oui mais je pense qu'ils assument
est dans toute son action
une fantaisie une flamme qui était
certainement nécessaire dans le domaine
de la culture de la création
alors c'est une très bonne réponse va me
permettre de vous demander si vous vous
mettez sur le compte de la fantaisie ou
de la flamme ce qu'il a dit dimanche
parce que d'abord il a suggéré de
rebaptiser le parti socialiste et de
l'appeler le parti de la vie évidemment
la majorité actuelle serait probablement
la mort est sans doute le parti
communiste les fantômes ou les spectres
est ce que ça vous irait d' d'être le
premier secrétaire du parti de la vie
nous avons dit que nous voulions changer
la vie nous avons vu au pouvoir que
c'était peut-être plus difficile que
nous le pensions être le parti de la vie
oui d'une partie de la vie pourquoi pas
comme d'autres il ya bien des partis qui
ont mis dans leur sigle le mot
république et cela ne veut pas dire
qu'ils considèrent que les autres sont
monarchistes et ils sont pas
républicains quand aider ça je suis
pressé ou qu'ils le sont à bord
intensément
alors jacques lang on va parler toute la
soirée jack lang m'enfin c'est lui qui a
parlé
jack lang a aussi employé une image un
peu flamboyante dans son style
il a expliqué que françois mitterrand
était un seigneur et celui bien entendu
un seigneur et qu'il était un géant puis
qu'à côté de lui tous ceux qui pensaient
pouvoir être candidat à la présidence de
la république qu'ils soient de gauche ou
de droite
c'était selon son expression des nains
est ce que c'est une une analyse de
sciences politiques qui vous paraît
fondé la comparaison m'avait frappé et
vous sachant s'agace je me suis dit que
vous auriez peut-être cette question
j'ai donc vu jacques l'angle des fuites
chez c'est gênant non pas du tout alors
non je me suis dit ça peut venir j'ai
pas pourquoi une espèce d'intuition j'ai
donc vu jacques lang y compris parce
qu'il souhaitait parler avec moi un peu
les problèmes de création de justement
la privatisation
je lui ai dit vêtu a vraiment pendant
cette phrase il m'a dit elle a été un
peu sorti de son contexte
donc je crois qu'il n'a pas exactement
dit ça mais de toute façon
ma vision à moi c'est que la démocratie
c'est fait pour des hommes des hommes
avec leur diversité mais la démocratie
c'est à hauteur d'homme alors justement
il disait comme on dit beaucoup d'autres
dirigeants socialistes peut être vous
même d'ailleurs que il souhaitait que
françois mitterrand soit de nouveau
candidat à la présidence de la
république en 1988 alors françois
mitterrand a été candidat une première
fois en 1965 une deuxième fois en 1974
une troisième fois en 1981 est-ce que
vous souhaiter qu'il soit une quatrième
fois en 1988
pour le moment il est président et non
pas candidat et je pense que il est bien
que les français mesuré je crois
d'ailleurs qui le mesure à quel point il
est président et qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire d'aborder maintenant le
problème ni de sa candidature ni d'une
autre candidature vous n'êtes donc pas
de préférence vous ce soit lui ou pas
lui la prochaine
non non non je pense que il est
président et que pour le moment dans une
situation par ailleurs assez complexe on
l'a vu je pense que c'est laid c'est
l'essentiel
alors je pose la question d'une autre
façon michel rocard aurait bien voulu
être candidat en 1981 et puis comme il
l'avait dit d'ailleurs il s'est effacé
devant françois mitterrand alors depuis
il a dit il a répété qu il voudrait bien
le candidat cette fois ci en 1988 est ce
que vous trouvez que c'est légitime de
ça parce que vous pensez qu'il a les
qualités de son ambition et est ce que
vous trouvez qu après tout c'est
peut-être son tour vous avez une façon
d'aborder ces problèmes qui est assez
étonnant
l'idée qu'il aimerait c'est mieux que si
c'était académique oui tout à fait don
mais je vais vous répondre avec la même
simplicité la même franchise je sais ce
que je pense pas je crois pas
honnêtement que ce soit une affaire de
tous maintenant que michel rocard pense
qu'il pourrait être candidat je le
comprends qu'ils se disent que en 1981
il a renoncé à cette candidature mais
après tout il aurait pu y en avoir
d'autres il renonçait à cette
candidature devant françois mitterrand
et que cette fois ci il aimerait bien y
aller je le comprends aussi comme
mécanisme psychologique qu'il ait des
qualités d'homme politique et d'homme
d'état
ça me paraît clair
d'homme d'état aussi homme d'état viril
suffit pas d'être ministre d'état pour
être un homme d'état un c'est pas des
tasses hépatite c ça s'mérite un homme
d'état est un homme qui a le sens de
l'état et qui au pouvoir démontre qu'il
a cette capacité de servir l'état
en tout cas l'état tel que je le conçois
pas l'état tel que semblait le concevoir
monsieur léotard la semaine dernière sur
cette même antenne je veux dire un état
démocratique un état dont on puisse être
fier parce qu'il représente la
collectivité des citoyens français
l'auteur n'est pas démocrate
pourquoi non je sais pas non mais une
pratique non alors j'ai été frappée
effectivement par la façon dont françois
léotard a parlé de l'état pendant toute
l'émission la semaine dernière car
j'avais l'impression qu'il parlait de
l'état comme si on était dans un état
des spots hic dans un état autoritaire
presque dans une dictature et c'était
étrange de voir un ministre de la
république normalement parlant au nom de
l'état à ce point critique et l'état et
vouloir absolument se mettre dans la
peau d'un simple citoyen et je dis qu'il
ya là un malentendu car je crois que
l'état dans une démocratie c'est ce qui
est fait pour incarner l'intérêt général
quand vous dites qu'ils parlaient l'état
comme s'ils étaient despotique et serra
est presque pas démocratique vous dire
de l'état tel qu'il est de l'état tel
qu'il fonctionne en france en démocratie
depuis 1945 depuis que nous sommes
sortis de la nuit du nazisme et de
l'occupation cet état et démocratique et
on avait l'impression que monsieur léo
tarn ne le voyais que dans une dimension
oppressive ça m'a paru surprenant pour
un ministre et pour quelqu'un qui aspire
il nous l'a dit avec tant d'ingénuité de
ferveur justement à être quoi chefs
d'état et vous et moi et vous je vous ai
dit qu'il y avait un président et que
l'essentiel à ça j'ai compris et les
téléspectateurs aussi c'est donc parce
que je vous demande alors qu'est ce que
vous me demandez et vous c'est une
formule ah non vous avez trouvé après
vous avez l'esprit vif et vous est-ce
que et vous aussi vous êtes aussi comme
françois léotard vous avez envie
la même génération bon vous êtes comme
lui le chef d'un parti important le
vôtre un peu plus que le sien d'ailleurs
m'enfin chef d'un parti
et vous est-ce que vous êtes déjà posé
la question pourquoi est ce que je ne
serai pas candidat à la présidence alors
je me suis posé la question et je ne
suis pas candidat non mais et vous ne le
serait pas et vous n'avez pas envie de
l'être plus de nos désirs non à gm
d'avoir envie honnêtement j'ai trouvé
étonnant de voir monsieur léotard
l'autre jour et j'ai pensé que c'était
un précédent sous notre république déjà
rappelez-vous sous de gaulle quand
monsieur pompidou d'un certain endroit à
rome je ferai avec mais à genève de
fruits avaient évoqué la possibilité de
sa candidature
rappelez vous à quel point ça avait été
un coup de tonnerre presque un peu un
objet de scandale
alors je dois dire que depuis du côté
des milieux conservateurs on a quand
même sacrément évolué parce que c'est la
première fois je crois que je vois un
ministre qui occupe un poste non
négligeable mais enfin par un des
premiers postes de l'état
justement dans une émission alors qu' il
est dans un gouvernement qu'il a un
premier ministre que ce le voit pour la
première fois faire acte de candidature
à la présidence de la république
je dois dire que ça m'a surpris est qu'à
propos des flottilles dont parlait
monsieur léotard sur un autre sujet j'ai
trouvé qu'il y avait du flottement dans
la flottille gouvernementale alors vous
alors alors que le jour où michel rocard
avait suggéré à la télévision de venir
chez lui pour annoncer qu'il était
candidat vous avez dû être horriblement
choqué parce que c'est le même de ces
mêmes principes
je pense que non je pense qu'il n'est
pas nécessaire de présenter sa
candidature maintenant mais dans le
casier nitrates
oui mais c'est un dans le cas de michel
rocard c'est une réalité historique il
l'a dit c'est son choix
j'ai pas d'autres commentaires à faire
pour le moment alors la grande majorité
pratiquement 4 sur 5 des français
souhaitent que les élections
présidentielles aient lieu en 1988 donc
alors date normale et puis que donc
d'ici là il ya la cohabitation bon parce
que vous êtes vous faites partie des 4
vous êtes le cinquième je crois m'être
exprimé clairement sur cette question je
suis pour que cette coexistence
institutionnels
aille jusqu'en 1988 bon alors comme ça
fait en gros deux mois et demi qu'elle
se déroule s'est pas encore un très long
recul mais enfin on commence à voir ce
genre de choses est ce que vous trouvez
que finalement pour la cinquième a
publié pour la démocratie et cetera
c'est plutôt une bonne chose que ça se
passe comme ça oui plutôt
d'abord les français l'ont voulu c'est
clair ils ont voté pour une autre
majorité ils n'ont en rien indiqué à
chaque fois qu'ils ont été questionnés
qu'il voulait changer le président de la
république du même coup et au contraire
depuis visiblement ils apportent au
président de la république une estime
qui croît sans cesse
deuxièmement et je crois qu'il faut donc
respecter le choix des français qui de
ces dernières années en sus dans des
échéances politiques dire clairement ce
qu'il voulait j'ai pu un peu regretté en
86 qui n'est pas voté davantage encore
pour le parti socialiste mais apparaît
logique en tout cas mais je le respecte
la deuxième chose c'est que je pense que
dans une démocratie et notamment en
france
il vaut mieux respecter les échéances et
la troisième raison c'est que je pense
personnellement que pour la france
faire cette expérience un peu difficile
ce n'est pas une mauvaise chose
alors est-ce que sur son rôle par la
force ne vous paraît pas un peu ambigu
aujourd'hui je veux dire le rôle du
président de la république en période de
cohabitation que n'ai pas le sentiment
que au fond il est toujours le chef de
l'état évidemment et qu'en même temps il
est un peu redevenu le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste à vos
côtés une affaire qu'il a en même temps
le président et puis le chef de
l'opposition n'ont en aucune façon dans
aucune façon ou alors il faudrait
admettre que pour démontrer que le chef
de l'état qui a était issu des rangs
socialistes et indiscutable n'ont rien à
voir avec l'opposition il faudrait que
le parti socialiste lui ne remplissent
pas son rôle d'opposition
ça c'est une absurdité et d'ailleurs ce
serait dangereux pour la démocratie
et en plus compte tenu de la politique
menée devant nous on parlera tout à
l'heure sur man je pense que
c'est quelque chose que nous ne pouvons
pas faire alors le président de la
république rempli je crois bien sa
fonction avec un sens de sa fonction que
les français reconnaissent et nous nous
remplissons notre rôle d'opposition
alors je crois qu'une question que
beaucoup de gens se posent c'est profond
de savoir un petit peu ce que ce qu'est
son rôle ou non d'inspirateur ou de
conseiller ou simplement d'observateurs
de l'action du parti socialiste
autrement dit bon avant avant mars
vous le voyez très souvent d'abord vous
prenez au moins un petit déjeuner par
semaine avec lui à l'elysée on en
parlait assez pour que vous vous
téléphoniez vous vous rencontrez y ait
beaucoup
est ce que vous le voyez autant qu'avant
ou pas le président de la république je
le vois plutôt moins je le vois pas de
façon régulière et institutionnels mais
il m'arrive de le voir et il m'arrive de
le joindre
alors quand par exemple on entend comme
ça arrive très souvent ce moment
plusieurs dirigeants du parti socialiste
le même jour le week-end en général les
hommes politiques s'expriment beaucoup
de week-end qui reprennent brusquement
le même thème à week-end alors ça change
la vie guen à l'autre est ce qu'il y est
pour quelque chose mais ce qui n'y est
pour rien il n'y est pour rien et dans
certains cas dans certains cas il s'agit
de coïncidences et dans d'autres cas de
d'une tendance d'une tentation je vais
vous en faire l'aveux qu'ont les
journalistes parfois a toujours
considéré que la politique est inspiré
par je ne sais quel chef d'orchestre au
fond nous sommes un pays qui a vécu des
siècles en monarchie et parfois je me
dis que certains observateurs de la vie
politique sont encore un petit peu sous
l'influencé de ce système monarchique de
penser en réalité
en réalité le président de la république
rempli sa fonction et nous remplissons
la nôtre et on s'occupe pas du tout des
affaires du parti socialiste jamais et
vous donne pas d'idées et vous fait pas
part de ses analyses
vous ne donnez pas ensemble à cette
occasion il vous dit pas comment ils
voient les choses et il ne suggère pas
que par exemple tel thème pour être
davantage mis en avant et que le
week-end suivant par exemple à
l'occasion des fêtes de la rose des
émissions des clubs de l'après steira ça
pourrait être pris
malraux a eu une belle phrase jadis qui
était dire l'homme n'est pas ce qu'il
cache
il est ce qu'il fait
eh bien je pense que ce serait absurde
de me demander à françois mitterrand et
à moi même et à quelques autres et à
pierre joxe et à d'autres encore que de
ne pas nous voir que de ne pas nous
parler nous sommes des amis nous nous
connaissons nous avons mené une action
politique ensemble
de la même manière les français seraient
stupéfaits troublé et sans doute même un
peu inquiet si françois mitterrand tout
d'un coup semblait tourner le dos aux
personnages historiques est tout
simplement à l'homme d'état qu'il a été
et qu'il est si tout d'un coup parce que
tel gouvernement propose la
privatisation de tf1 il applaudissait
que parce qu'il sut propose de supprimer
l'autorisation administrative de
licenciement il le souhaitait m avec un
sourire complice
cela n'est pas possible simplement
françois mitterrand ne mène pas bataille
comme nous le faisons nous au parlement
compte des projets néfastes
parfois il dit son sentiment pour le
reste il l'est le gouvernement gouverner
pour les domaines de salive étant posé
et le parti socialiste s'oppose et met
alors à rester devant et vous imaginez
une autre situation et moi j'imagine
rien du tout mais non justement vous
avez cité à l'instant père joxe qui est
le lancer misé intérieur et l'actuel
président de groupe parlementaire
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale alors
et est-ce qu'il n'ya pas une
contradiction entre lionel jospin le
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
qui nous dit mais l'échéance normale
régulière souhaitable c'est 88
et puis pierre joxe le leader de groupe
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale
qui lui organise disons une contestation
quotidienne particulièrement intense des
projets du gouvernement et pour être
plus précis est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
contradiction aussi entre lionel jospin
et lionel jospin
c'est à dire lionel jospin 10 ans se
plaignant à une émission de radio ya pas
très longtemps mais ce gouvernement ne
gouverne pas il faut qu'ils gouvernent
et puis maintenant lionel jospin
multipliant les embûches des traquenards
les difficultés pour que le gouvernement
justement gouverne le moins possible
j'ai beau avoir épousé une psychologue
je ne suis pas schizophrène il n'y a pas
de lionel jospin
c'est vraiment bien parce que ça arrive
quelquefois certains hommes peu
c'est bien de ne pas en être pas du tout
alors ce que je veux dire
sur ce plan c'est que nous vivons dans
un système avec un parlement
évidemment pourrait dire l'élection a eu
lieu une majorité s'est dégagée pendant
six mois on met le parlement en vacances
car le gouvernement nouveau ayant une
majorité il est normal qu'il fasse
passer sans problème
toutes ces dispositions ce n'est pas le
cas nous vivons dans toutes les
démocraties avec un gouvernement qui
doit se présenter devant un parlement
parfois l'affronter affronter son
opposition
et c'est ainsi qu'on pratique la
politique dans les démocraties pas en
mettant en parenthèse ou en vacances le
parlement bien c'est ce que vous disais
l'opposition de l'époque en 1982 pas
tout à fait
c'était la deuxième chose que j'allais
dire voyez tout à fait effectivement
nous avons fonctionné dans ces
circonstances et dans ce contexte et
nous avons eu devant nous une opposition
très forte parfois même une très bonne
réputation parfois même une caricature
de nos positions mais pourquoi nous nous
opposons effectivement avec eux je crois
une certaine efficacité parce que nous
pensons que les projets qui nous sont
proposés ne sont pas bons pour les
français je vais je réponds si vous me
permettez de donner un argument très
simple d'accord parce que si croyez vous
que si le gouvernement proposait des
mesures au parlement qui nous paraissent
bonnes pour le pays et pour les français
croyez vous que nous pourrions où nous
aurions voté contre
depuis qu'ils sont arrivés à de paix
qu'ils ont gagné depuis deux mois et
demi il n'y a pas eu une mesure proposée
qui vous est convenu on pourra rentrer
dans le détail des soins une seule ans
alors on vient ce qu'on disait je peux
en donner une ou deux par exemple des
mesures prises dans la loi
d'habilitation économique et social et
qui vise à favoriser l'emploi des jeunes
prolongent une action que nous avions
mené notamment michel delebarre
mais le fait par exemple de diminuer les
charges étaient certaines entreprises
qui embaucheront des jeunes nous avons
utilisé le même type de stimulation peut
pas être contre cela si vous voulez
parmi les mesures qui touchent par
exemple la lutte contre l'insécurité est
par exemple contre le terrorisme nous
avons mené gaston defferre d'abord
pierre joxe ensuite une lutte résolue
contre l'insécurité et le terrorisme
bon je veux bien donner une parce que
moi j'ai des inquiétudes sur beaucoup de
thé j'espère qu'on y reviendra tout
c'est sûrement par exemple l'idée de
dire que tous les quatre terroristes
seront soumis à la même juridiction pas
attention pas une haute cour de sûreté
de l'état quand même on n'a rien seul
juge d'instruction
c'est une telle juridiction sans doute
que c'est plus cohérent sans doute que
c'est plus cohérent
voila je viens de vous en donner deux
dans des dimensions tout à fait
différente
je reviens et je dois dire que tient à
vous me donnez de veiller à l'aise et et
vous permet trier auvray lionel jospin
de s'exprimer si vous me demandiez les
mesures qui ne me plaisent pas bon mais
ça je voulais demanderait pas parce que
on imagine qu y en a quelques-unes
c'est plus original le savoir celle que
vous approuvez oui mais l année c'est
quand même que pour le responsable que
je suis il est au moins aussi important
ce soir que je commente l'action du
gouvernement en place avec tous les
commentaires par gramme de l'ancien
ministre de la culture met d'accord mais
vous reconnaîtrez aussi que c'est normal
que quand on reçoit un homme politique
quelle que soit sa tendance à condition
de faire de même avec tous les hommes
politiques quels que soient leurs
tendances
on essaie plutôt de leur poser des
questions qui les gêne que celles qui
leur sont aimables c'est la règle
bon alors est ce qu a pas un petit quand
même un problème
bon vous dites il faut que le parlement
exerce son rôle s'il faut plus parlement
exerce son rôle mais est ce que un
gouvernement qui vient de gagner des
élections
qui donc a envie de commencer une
politique nouvelle
bon c'est ce que les français ont voulu
puisque une majorité petite ou grande a
voté pour est ce que c'est ce qui a pas
quelque chose de de compliquer dans btan
et un peu de frustrant pour tout le
monde
de ralentir tellement de mouvement
quelquefois de donner le sentiment de
jouer un peu la montre comme on dit au
football et et de l'empêcher au fond de
commencer vraiment ce qu'il a à faire au
début je dis hôpital laisser-faire puis
ensuite à critiquer elle devait pas
parler longuement de la dimension
parlementaire ou de procédure ne
repartirai snow russes les français mais
c'est un instant sur ce point il faut
quand même que vous sachiez que si un
certain nombre de projets ont tardé à
être finalement examiné ou voter c'est
d'une part parce qu'ils ont été amendés
souvent
aussi par la majorité elle même je pense
par exemple au collectif budgétaire et
le gouvernement a dû se battre pour
faire reculer certains amendements par
exemple celui qui les autorisait à
nouveau les machines à sous avec toutes
les fraudes que ça peut permettre ou
bien les mesures qui tendaient les
femmes veulent en être heureuse à
remettre en cause les ressources
permettant le contrôle des naissances et
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
est d'accord je dis c'est normal que le
parlement joue son rôle
c'est une chose est ce que le
gouvernement peut gouverner la surtout
au début la deuxième
la deuxième chose qui a retardé les
projets c'est que parfois le
gouvernement n'était pas prêt c'est à
dire qu'il a dû lui même amendé ses
propres textes
alors donc ce n'est pas de votre faute
quoi et là on touche au coeur du
problème effectivement moi ce qui me
frappe c'est que monsieur chirac avait
dit il me faudra 100 jours pour créer la
confiance créé le dynamise par le seul
fait que nous allons arriver ça y est
les carcans vont se lever les chefs
d'entreprise vont investir ils vont
embaucher et ce qui me fera alors que
nous approchons du 80ème jours et qu'il
n'en reste plus que 20 et ça ça fera
tous les acteurs amateurs qui aiment
jours après on apprend après 16 ans il a
eu à partir de la formation du
gouvernement pour être honnête il a été
nommé chacun en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que tout le monde se rend compte
que cette confiance n'a pas été créé que
ce dynamisme
il n'est pas là alors je crois que c'est
la première constatation que nous
faisons tous et une journée 20 je vais
vous donner un exemple
oui moi j'ai une question donnée si la
confiance n'existe pas s'il n'y a pas un
bon climat
comment est ce que vous expliquez que de
même que vous disiez je ne faisais pas
interrompue parce que c'était vrai que
les sondages étaient bons pour françois
mitterrand de même ils sont bons pour
jacques chirac
j'attends les prochains non mais parlons
ce qu'on connaît pas ce qu'on va pas
sortir de notre poche ces sondages que
personne ne connaît à sa main abba
peut-être mais ça serait pas correct
d'accord alors oublié sur sakho souvenez
vous de ce que je dis ce soir
bon alors en gros vous trouvez que il
n'est pas populaire du tout un nom à bon
50 je veux dire la confiance c'est ça
aussi une niche n'est pas du tout parlé
de popularité large audience
non mais la popularité de monsieur
chirac c'est pas le problème pour moi
d'abord ensuite il a été élu par une
majorité
faible à l'assemblée nationale mais une
majorité tout de même bien qu'ils ne
représentaient pas eu d frbr vous le
savez plus de 40 2% je crois des
français bien donc son droit à gouverner
et entier je dis simplement que monsieur
chirac avait dit nous arriverons et nous
créerons le choc psychologique chez les
acteurs économique qui permettra de
relancer les choses je constate que ce
choc n'est pas créée bien au contraire
et quand j'entends monsieur noir
ministre du commerce extérieur dire que
le commerce extérieur va s'aggraver
quand j'entends monsieur séguin
contredire monsieur chirac en disant que
le chômage va s'aggraver alors que
monsieur chirac avait dit ici même à
l'heure de vérité que toute sa politique
était fondée en direction de l'emploi
mais il avait il avait pas d contraire
non plus ça c'était jacques toubon vous
me direz que ce n'est pas très différent
mais je ne vais pas je me je me dis que
cette confiance ce dynamisme n'est pas
créée prenons l'exemple de la
suppression de l'autorisation
administrative de licenciement
nous allons nous battre et nous sommes
en train de nous battre au parlement et
dans le pays pour lutter contre si
jamais quelques personnalités
conservatrices mais qui trouvent que
c'est une mesure finalement un peu
stupide par adaptée à la situation
voté contre et que le texte ne passerait
pas j'en serai ravi
enfin les patrons doivent se dire que si
monsieur chirac utilise le 49-3 ce texte
passera
pourquoi n'anticipe t-il pas et ne
crée-t-il pas d un miroir justement
est-ce que vous mourriez justement est
ce que vraiment dernière dernière
question ça c'est ennuyeux bon alors
dernière question somme en vingt-et-une
leur dernière question c'est vraiment la
dernière bombe dernière question
honnêtement un but vous aimez bien dire
les choses comme vous les voyez dans
honnêtement est-ce que pour que un chef
d'entreprise investissent vous pensez
qu'il est encourageant de prendre des
risques financiers qui pour lui sont
importants quand justement trois fois
par semaine on dit mme attention au
risque une dissolution nourrissent
qu'une démission et que bon par exemple
on voit un journal
américain qui titre en première page le
président rappelle qui peut mettre ça ce
qui se passe autrement dit quand tu es
une incertitude politique quand on sait
pas quand ce sont des élections quand on
sait pas quand sur les échéances est-ce
qu'on investit le président de la
république à ma connaissance a toujours
dit qu'il voulait jouer le jeu
démocratique de cette situation nouvelle
il n'a en aucun cas du pacte un tyran
non question n'est pas posée
vous parliez des rythmes il n'a à aucun
moment dit qu'il voulait précipiter ses
rites je suis le premier secrétaire du
parti le plus important de l'opposition
considère comme proche du président de
la république on a raison je dis moi
même depuis plusieurs semaines déjà que
nous devons poursuivre cette expérience
jusqu'en 1988
l'argument de la précarité ne tient pas
et ben voilà c'est une réponse
voilà bon merci alain duhamel or
justement sur cette question de la durée
de la cohabitation
pendant que vous prétendiez alain
duhamel nous avons sondé sofres à son
départ télé sondage les français qui
nous regardent ce soir sur la question
pensez vous que le parti socialiste
souhaite souhaite vraiment que la
cohabitation dure jusqu'à 88 voilà les
réponses de les voir jusqu'en 88 64 %
des gens pensent que les socialistes
lors leurs voeux réel et que ça dure que
on y mettre fin le plus tôt possible 19
% seulement des gens sans opinion 17
pour ça donc c'est une réponse très très
directe à ce que vous venez de dire sur
les attentions du président alors une
deuxième question qui a été posée sur
l'obstruction je ne suis pas absolument
sûr coller encore les réponses à
l'assemblée nationale estimez vous que
le ps fait de l'obstruction contre le
gouvernement ou qu'il joue son rôle
normal d'opposants alors fait
obstruction 40 2% joue son rôle normal
52 % sans opinion 6 % un commentaire
jeudi c'est le contenu de la politique
qui détermine notre attitude si les
mesures étaient plus positive nous
n'aurions pas de problème et même quand
on parle de la coexistence reconnaissait
que pour le président de la république
est aussi pour nous mêmes mais notamment
pour le président la république mener
une politique de co existence alors que
on s'apprête donc on veut en tout cas je
ne sais pas si on y parviendra à
privatiser tf1 la plus en chine
sienne chaînes publiques françaises
mener une politique politique de co
existence alors qu'on s'apprête à
privatiser des banques des compagnies
d'assurances un certain nombre
d'industries qui était nationalisé en
france depuis plus de 40 ans d'accord
c'est difficile le la politique du
gouvernement n'est pas vraiment une
politique dépasse 10 ans donc de voir
que notre mérite est assez grand le
problème là n'est pas de la justesse de
vos positions il est de la perception
par les français
est ce que ça vous satisfait que
effectivement 52% des français
considèrent que vous jouez votre rôle
normal d'opposants par votre action
parlementaire actuelle oui ça me paraît
clair et ça m'apparaît important je
crois d'ailleurs que c'est ce que les
gens pensent parce qu'il m'en parle
svp une autre question oui justement
monsieur jospin pourquoi êtes-vous
tellement opposé à la privatisation
d'une chaîne de télévision
et qu'est ce qui vous gêne dans le fait
que ce soit tf1 honnêtement j'ai pas de
préférence négative si j'ose dire ni
pour tf1 ni pour antenne 2 ce qui me
gêne ce sont les éléments suivants
premiers éléments
aucun pays au monde n'a jamais
privatisée une chaîne publique
il doit bien y avoir des raisons
deuxième élément
pourquoi un bien public
une chaîne qui est la première chaîne
française à l'origine
pourquoi un bien public serait t'il
arraché à la collectivité nationale et
donner tout d'un coup à quelques
détenteurs privés à des groupes
financiers ou à des groupes de
communication
je ne vois pas la raison à cela
troisièmement nous savons tous que
privatiser serait faire passer une
chaîne de service public dans le statut
d'une chaîne commerciale et nous savons
qu'une chaîne commerciale ne peut pas
assumer les mêmes contraintes ont
représenté et de créances bras statut
commercial le problème c'est pas le
statut juridique le vrai problème c'est
le contenu des programmes
on peut avoir un statut de sociétés
commerciales et des obligations de
service public
mais lolo en france et distribué par des
compagnies privées qui assument des
missions d'intérêt général
cela peut se faire et c'est bien
pourquoi nous mêmes au l'édifice des
chaînes publiques nous avons ajouté nous
mêmes par une démarche positive et non
pas par une démarche
négative l'addition de chaîne privée
canal+ ça n'a pas marché
sauf pour canal+ sono canal+ ça va pas
marcher pour les autres donc on vient
chercher une autre voie nous nous avons
fait canal + je devrai tout de même pas
qu'on fasse de tf1 canal - honnêtement
il ya mieux à faire et en plus qu'est-ce
qu'on donnerait on donnerait cette
chaîne clé en main avec toute son
histoire ses talents sa création ses
moyens financiers tout cela serait
bradée littéralement à des entreprises
privées
je n'en vois pas l'intérêt avec en plus
un dernier risque sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est qu'on sait que quels sont
les acheteurs potentiels pour tf1 on
nous parle de monsieur r sans écouter
qui véhiculent dans certains de ses
journaux une idéologie qui à la limite
de la droite et de l'extrême droite
on nous parle de monsieur lagardère j'ai
rien contre enfin il se trouve que
l'activité principale de monsieur
lagardère est quand même la vente
d'armes avec matra je ne crois pas pour
une grande démocratie il soit idéale de
donner éventuellement une chaîne
publique appartenant à tout le monde à
des détenteurs privés aussi particulier
vous êtes d'avis qu'il faut arrêter les
ventes d'armes les exportations d'armes
je considère et vous pouvez pas attaqué
et en même temps avoir un avis sur le
fond je considère que les marchands
d'armes doivent faire bien leur métier
tant qu' on ne peut pas réduire le
nombre des armes dans le monde ce qui
est mon opinion et mon souhait mais qui
sont pas faits pour faire de la
télévision c'est à dire pour transmettre
des idées et pour transmettre le
pluralisme
a priori je préfère que ce soit des
hommes de télévision qui le fasse et non
par les marchands d'armes bien alors
jean marie colombani maintenant face à
vous pour un quart d'heure jean marie
colombani chef du service politique du
monde
tout à l'heure on a parlé cohabitation
on a parlé du rôle du président de la
république et puis on a parlé des
projets de lois des ordonnances mais je
voudrais que vous précisiez un petit peu
les choses sur les ordonnances
est-ce que vous même vous souhaitez que
l'une ou l'autre ordonnance que le
président de la république aura assigné
réforme du mode de scrutin ou bien
privatisation il refuse de donner cette
signature parce que tout à l'heure vous
nous avez dit quand le parlement vote la
loi le président ne peut rien mais quand
il a signé une ordonnance il peut
refuser sa signature alors est ce que le
chef du parti socialiste souhaite que le
président refuse sa signature vous
répondre me permet peut-être d'éclairer
une des questions que nous posait alain
duhamel tout à l'heure sur la non
confusion des genres et je ne veux pas
dans un domaine qui est de la
prérogative même du droit même du
président de la république exprimé mon
opinion
si j'en ai une je la lui donnerai s'il
fait tel ou tel acte tel ou tel choix
je pourrais éventuellement donner mon
sentiment mais là c'est son pouvoir
c'est son droit je ne ferai rien avant
le moment où il aura pose à se poser
cette question pour d'une certaine façon
ou d'une autre
intervenir dans ce que sont ses
prérogatives je ne veux pas de confusion
des genres je suis désolé de ne pas
pouvoir répondre à votre question mais
c'est justement pour que pour les
français il soit bien établi que le
président joue un rôle particulier qui
n'a pas renoncé à ses convictions qu'il
dira ce qu'il croit être l'intérêt de la
france mais qu'en même temps il est
président de tous les français est moins
j'anime un fort un formidable mouvement
politique mais une partie seulement de
l'opinion on va revenir au parti
socialiste tout à l'heure restons un
petit peu sur ses problèmes
institutionnels vous dit le président
est maître etc
le président avait un pouvoir presque
absolu pendant cinq ans très fort
monarchique vous nous reprochez souvent
d'avoir les yeux la monarchie dans les
yeux mais ça y ressemble quand même
beaucoup
et puis tout d'un coup le voilà privé de
beaucoup de chose de beaucoup de pouvoir
alors est-ce que ce balancement vous
convient ou est ce que vous pensez qu'à
terme il faudra réformer la constitution
par exemple ramener le mandat cinq ans
comme le président l'avait lui-même
envisagé comme
le président pompidou l'avait aussi
envisagé et c'est l'intérêt de la
situation actuelle que je n'ai pas
choisi je me suis efforcé au contraire
de faire qu'elles ne se produisent pas
c'est qu'elle permet de montrer
qu'effectivement la constitution peut
fonctionner de façon plus équilibrée
avec des pouvoirs plus grands pour le
premier ministre et mon intuition est
que à l'avenir
et quel que soit le prochain président
de la république est le prochain premier
ministre
le premier ministre jouera un rôle plus
important dans notre constitution
faut-il la réforme et nous nous sommes
effectivement fixé comme objectif au
sein du parti socialiste que de discuter
de cette question et d'examiner comment
cela peut être fait dans quel sens
faut-il aller vers plus de régime
parlementaire c'est-à-dire le système
qui fonctionne actuellement un
gouvernement responsable devant sa
majorité est un président qu'ils ont un
monarque constitutionnel si l'on veut ou
bien vers un système plus présidentiel
où le président quoi qu'il arrive
auraient le pouvoir exécutif et serait
en négociations avec un parlement
indépendante lui indépendant du
gouvernement
tu crois que pour le moment il étonné de
vous dire que les deux tendances existe
chez nous et c'est assez normal parce
que au fond ce système étant un système
mixte ni présidentiel ni parlementaire
on peut selon qu'on va dans un sens ou
dans l'autre le faire pencher dans le
sens présidentielle où dans le sens
parlementaire je préférerais que la
discussion s'engage et je pense qu'elle
s'engagera d'ailleurs de façon
relativement discrète avant de donner
mon propre sentiment sur ce point ma
tendance est quand même plutôt de
considérer qu' il est bon que un
parlement vivent bien avant d'en venir
aux parties si je voudrais rester un
petit moment sur la politique du
gouvernement vous avez devant vous je
crois pierre bérégovoy qu'est ce qui
distingue aujourd'hui pierre bérégovoy
d'edouard balladur
est-ce que franchement vous voyez
beaucoup de différence entre la
politique d'edouard balladur la
politique économique chantant et celle
de pierre bérégovoy est ce qui a une
différence de style où il ya une
différence de fond les patrons préfèrent
balladur et les chefs d'entreprise
commencent à regretter bérégovoy mais ça
ce sont des formules
oui mais c'est pas interdit de faire des
formules quand elles ont un sens je veux
par là que pierre bérégovoy il y a eu
une fonction essentielle mais aussi bien
sûr le gouvernement dans lequel ils
agissaient honte je crois aider à des
évolutions importantes de l'économie
nous avons stabilisé les prix et je
constate que ils sont en train de
repartir l'inflation repart nous avons
on peut travailler et discrétion il ya
travaillé à redresser le commerce
extérieur avec encore des problèmes et
je constate que à cause de la
dévaluation le commerce extérieur est en
train de se creuser
nous avons été confrontés de façon
difficile au problème de l'emploi
nous n'avons pas totalement réussi c'est
clair c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles les français finalement nous
ont sanctionnés démocratiquement mais je
ne crois pas que la façon dont le
gouvernement s'oriente l'amène à
améliorer les choses
en tout cas je crois justement que la
politique du gouvernement montrent
clairement que même sans sectarisme la
gauche et la droite c'est pas pareil
pierre bérégovoy il a pas su priver
l'impôt sur les grandes fortunes
il a pas faciliter l'action des
fraudeurs que ce soit du fisc ou de la
douane se sont abaissés de 5 % l'impôt
sur les sociétés en ce qui concerne les
bénéfices lui il avait baissé pour les
investissements et non pas pour les
bénéfices des mesures voyez les
conférences que vous fassiez des thèmes
politiques mais qui sont j'allais dire
la marge à la périphérie d'une politique
économique on n'a pas l'impression
qu'ils aient une telle rupture dans le
cours de la politique économique elle
même le discours de monsieur balladur
est toujours un discours sur la rigueur
celui de monsieur bérégovoy était aussi
un discours sur la rigueur tout
gouvernement est confronté au problème
des grands équilibres les prix la
balance des échanges extérieurs
le budget et tout gouvernement est
confronté à des problèmes plus dynamique
plus à long terme la croissance et
l'emploi
donc tout gouvernement traite de ces
questions qui sont les grandes questions
économiques et sociales
mais je pense que le style politique au
contraire les choix politiques sont très
différents quand vous voyez le collectif
budgétaire et que dans le même temps on
économise on s'apprête à économiser 4
milliard en supprimant l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes
oui mais quand même moment mais c'est
moi terminer parce que c'est très
important comme m
man on renonce à l'augmentation qui
était prévue pour le 1er juillet de
l'indemnité pour les handicapés de
l'indemnité pour les personnes âgées et
des retraites
quand dans le même moment on libéralise
la fraude et que dans le même moment on
impose un droit de 150 francs pour
passer un examen ou 250 francs pour
passer le permis de conduire
je veux dire c'est presque de façon les
presque provocante ou flamboyante oui
que ce gouvernement montrent les choix
qu'il fait c'est pour le sait sur la
manière mais sur le fond scène tous les
soirs le font les gouvernements
précédents avaient eux mêmes reconnu la
nécessité de comprimer les dépenses
publiques de faire des économies de
réduire le train de vie de l'état
monsieur balladur accentue un petit peu
cet effort peut-être si vous étiez resté
au gouvernement vous auriez vous aussi
accentuer cet effort je crois oui vous
m'aidez peut-être a précisé mieux encore
ce que je veux dire je veux dire que les
mêmes objectifs existent mais les moyens
de politique économique on utilise les
catégories de la population qu'on
épargne ou au contraire qu'on charge ne
sont pas les mêmes
sensiblement lorsqu'il y a un
gouvernement de gauche et lorsqu'il y
ait un gouvernement de droite et c'est
cela que je voulais démontrer
oui il faut essayer de contrôler les
équilibres mais pourquoi le libéralisme
vaut-il pour les prix pourquoi le
libéralisme vaut-il pour les changes
pourquoi le libéralisme vaut-il pour les
profits et tout d'un coup pour pointe ne
vaut-il pas pour les salaires les
retraites ou les pensions
si on croit au libéralisme on devrait y
croire dans toutes les directions
c'est là où on voit que étonnamment nous
qui ne parlons pas trop paraît-il
actuellement de lutte de classe ou de
classe c'est là où on voit que c'est
finalement le gouvernement chirac qui
dit il y a des classes et entre ses
classes je fais des choix très que vous
allez revenir au discours sur la lutte
des classes mais moi je n'ai pas besoin
de revenir au discours monsieur chirac
malheureusement se chargent de la
pratique
justement est ce que finalement vous
vous êtes dans une situation extrêmement
confortable vous étiez en campagne
électorale il ya quelques mois en
campagne électorale votre rôle c'était
de valoriser
l'action des précédents gouvernements
qu'ils étaient des vôtres et puis de
critiqué les propositions de
l'opposition mais de proposition de vous
il y en avait pas ou peu aujourd'hui
vous êtes dans l'opposition
et vous avez simplement à critiquer
l'action du gouvernement mais qu'elles
seront ou quelles sont vos propositions
on a un petit peu l'impression que le
parti socialiste que vous dirigez est en
panne d'idées sur sedan semaine
honnêtement pas s'impliquent avant
d'avoir épuisé disons les charmes de la
gestion vous avez épuisé l'imagination
si il n'y a pas de gestion sans idée les
indications que je donnais sur les
politiques économiques dans les deux cas
montrait qu'on se rattachait à des
valeurs et à des conceptions différentes
mais il est vrai que tant que nous
étions gouvernement nous n'avions pas
tellement à pratiquer des théories
puisque nous gouvernons que les français
pouvaient nous juger sur ce que nous
faisions maintenant nous sommes dans une
situation différente mais en même temps
les français qui viennent de voter
n'attendent pas de nous que dans les
trois mois
dans les 65 jours les 80 jours dont on
parlait tout à l'heure à nouveau nous
prétendions que nous avons un programme
surtout non je crois qu'ils s'attendent
à ce que nous disions comme une
opposition ce que nous pensons de ce que
fait le gouvernement
quand nous présentons des amendements
dans le débat parlementaire ça esquisse
une autre vision des choses
par exemple l'autorisation
administrative de licenciement pour être
concret nous disons non
c'est une faute actuellement que de
rendre plus faciles les licenciements et
moi je vois à paris même ou en province
je vois les trains de licenciement qui
commencent à partir
mais le train de l' embauche dont
parlait monsieur chirac celui là pour le
moment il est resté en gare
alors nous nous disons il ne faut pas
faire ça mais faire ça mais vous n'aimez
pas ce qu'il faut faire pour hydro
contraire si vous pouviez je reconnais
que c'est parfois difficile et vous êtes
un bon observateur de la vie politique
mais si vous assistiez de prêts au débat
parlementaire qui parfois se passe la
nuit
vous verriez que les amendements
présentés que ce soit par aux routes ou
soit par deux le barp soit portofino
pour parler des parlementaires qui mène
cette action est bien propose une visite
différentes par exemple sur les
négociations avec les syndicats
par exemple sur la charge de la preuve
nous disons il faudrait que comme en
allemagne lorsqu'il y à licenciement ce
soit aux chefs d'entreprise au patron de
dire pourquoi il licencie et non pas aux
salariés de faire la preuve on nous
avons fait toute une série de contre
propositions concrètes
on va pas examiné ici dans ce débat mais
qui témoigne d'une conception différente
reconnaissez qu'elle n'apparaît pas au
grand jour cette conception et que c'est
pourquoi j'essaye d'en parler ici à
parti qui prétend incarner l'espoir pour
demain et c est plutôt pour l'instant en
panne d'idées en panne de projet disons
je viens un projet que vous aviez pour
partie a été entrepris pour partie a
échoué
quels autres projets pour demain et ça
les socialistes pour l'instant ne le
disent pas il faudra d'abord savoir dans
deux ans comment les français jugeront
la politique de la gauche
malgré ses imperfections après deux ans
de la politique de la droite
j'aimerais bien savoir mais je ne veux
pas m'avancer ou non d'être battue il
faut le savoir et nous avons très
calmement très sereinement à travailler
pour une future alternance car nous
serons là fort de l'alternance est
certainement pas prétendre que nous
allons le faire maintenant
pourquoi pourquoi au fond avez vous été
battu est-ce que vous avez vous à vos
questions oui j'en ai un certain nombre
d'abord je crois que quand on est une
coalition nous avons gouverné avec les
communistes pendant plusieurs années et
qu'une partie de ceux qui doivent vous
aider passent l'essentiel de leur temps
à vous critiquez
honnêtement ça suscite pas
l'enthousiasmé ça c'est une première
raison deuxième raison je crois que nous
avons en partie échoué contre
le chômage nous avons fait des progrès
nous avons mis en place des instruments
mais nous n'avons pas réussi à restaurer
le plein emploi et je crois d'ailleurs
qu'il sera très difficile pour tout
gouvernement de le faire troisièmement
je pense que sur certains points nous
avons même animé des meilleures
intentions du monde heurter l'opinion et
nous l'avons compris après nous en avons
tenu compte mais ça s'est produit par
exemple sur la question de l'école c'est
un fait
je pense enfin que il était difficile de
gouverner un pays en période de crise
économique mais que vers la fin je pense
que nous étions en train de le redresser
sérieusement et puis nous avions avancé
des projets d'avenir notamment en ce qui
concerne la recherche
enfin toujours est il que ayant été
désavoué vous avez fait vous même
allusion tout à l'heure à votre allié
communiste qui n'est plus là il y a plus
d'alliance à gauche le parti socialiste
fait 32% comment espérez-vous
reconquérir le pouvoir avec 32% des voix
ce que vous n'êtes pas condamné
aujourd'hui pour longtemps à
l'opposition une opposition certes
active mais condamné pour longtemps à
l'opposition faute d'avoir des alliés
juste un instant pour ne pas donner
l'impression de laisser en panne votre
question sur mon projet en pagne
paraît-il j'aimerais vous dire que vous
le savez bien que j'ai lancé il y a
quelques semaines quinze jours dix jours
le groupe des experts du parti
socialiste c'est à dire que des hommes
et des femmes dont certains sont les
premiers dans leur discipline dans leur
métier dans leur spécialité scientifique
ou économique ou social dont certains
sont même les premiers au monde des
hommes et des femmes de talent ayant une
expérience de terrain sont dans tous les
domaines prêts à travailler librement
avec nous sont intéressés par ce que
représente parti socialiste et vont sur
tous les sujets nous faire des
propositions
débattre avec nous c'est à dire que nous
sommes en train de réélaboration projet
mais ce projet vous avez y va tenir
compte à la fois de ce que la droite
fait sous nos yeux aussi en partie de ce
que nous avons fait au gouvernement
et pour le faire
vous les plombs quand vous serez prêt
corps mais oui mais mais dans le
résultat c'est pour quand le résultat de
ces travaux que vous lancez maintenant
si le président de la république décide
de brusquer les échéances il en a la
possibilité
c'est même actuellement votre principale
à tout-va trois sépales chances de
revenir au pouvoir
bon ok c'est la possibilité de me lever
et de quitter ce plateau ce serait
d'ailleurs stupide de le faire parce que
je me trouve très agréablement accueilli
cette conversation en tout cas moi
m'intéresse et je n'utilise pas cette
possibilité
je ne vois pas pourquoi le président de
la république voudrait nécessairement
précipiter ces échéances
en tout cas nous nous travaillons par
rapport aux échéances normales je les
dis et donc je pense que nos
propositions nouvelles pour l'alternance
seront prêtes ou devrait pouvoir être
examinés déjà au congrès que nous
tiendrons à la fin 2009 185 mettons que
le projet soit mairie fiq idéal mettons
que l'échéance viennent à terme 1988
comment espérez vous convaincre les
français de voter pour vous alors que
vous êtes en panne d'allier là aussi
vous n'avez pas d'alliés et vous ne
faites que un tiers du corps électoral
comment pouvez-vous prétendre rallier
une majorité
alors vous me direz il ya le président
wimille président le son mandat viendra
bien à son terme
nous faisons effectivement le tiers du
corps électoral aucun parti ne fait
autant mais nous on le dira du corps
électoral parce que nous avons été
battus si nous voulons gagner il nous
faudra faire beaucoup plus et je pense
qu'il faudra surtout que notre candidat
aux élections présidentielles face
beaucoup plus mais je jouerai nous
attirer votre attention sur une donnée
immédiat qui peut-être apporte un
élément de réponse à votre question il
ya eu plusieurs sondages ou plusieurs
questions qui ont été posées en fonction
de candidat différent du parti
socialiste contre des candidats
différents de la droite
ces derniers jours dans un journal et
j'ai constaté une chose c'est que selon
les cas on donnait 52 48 pour le
socialiste 51 49 pour le socialiste
50/50 socialiste droite ou 49 51 dans le
plus mauvais cas pour le socialiste
classe à la droite ce qui veut dire pour
l'élection présidentielle pour
l'élection présidentielle précisant ce
qui veut dire que
une idée que le candidat présenté par
les socialistes pourraient rassembler 50
% ou ce qu'il faut pour gagner un peu
plus de 50% des voix
cet idéal est tout à fait par exemple
dans les réponses des français aux
sondages et avec quelle majorité
gouvernementale est ce qu'on ne ferait
pas on retomberait pas dans le cas de
figures actuelles c'est-à-dire un
président socialiste peut-être les
contraintes gouverner avec une majorité
de droite faute pour le ps d'obtenir une
majorité suffisante
je suis surtout un moment vers namur des
alliés je suis sûr que le moment venu
les français nous donneront des
indications il nous ils nous diront quel
autre choix nous aussi nous aurons des
choix à faire
en tout cas la prochaine échéance
présidentielle vous l'avez dit vous-même
et je pense que un socialiste peut
gagner les élections présidentielles si
nous travaillons bien sérieusement
modestement mais avec imagination dans
les deux ans qui viennent
juste une dernière question mais je vais
revenir à l'économie
le nouveau ministre de l'industrie à la
madelin a récemment à l'assemblée
nationale indiqué qu'elle était sa
politique la tonalité de sa politique
c'est plutôt moins de subventions
libéralisme oblige et il a cité comme
exemple alors de subventions tout à fait
abusive voire électoralistes les
subventions attribuées à al usine de la
chapelle darblay qui produit du papier
alors voudrais savoir quel est votre
sentiment sur ces subventions là j'ai
trouvé vraiment que c'était une
polémique assez politicienne comme il
convient de dire maintenant parce que la
chapelle darblay et d'apple avait des
arguments chiffrés pour montrer que ils
ont le seuil de la normale je veux vous
dire mon sentiment
les arguments monsieur madelin ils ont
été données saida vous donner les miens
maintenant je crois que il s'agit d'une
polémique politique mené contre l'ancien
premier ministre laurent fabius qui
avait d'ailleurs déjà été mené lorsqu'il
était ministre puis premier ministre
cette entreprise est une entreprise très
importante
fabrication de papier et c'est une
entreprise qui est pratiquement unique
en son genre à savoir que si nous
l'avions laissé couler malgré ces
difficultés nous sommes pas responsables
ces difficultés c'était pas une
entreprise publique c'est pas un
socialiste qui la gérait mais si malgré
ces difficultés nous l'avions laissé
couler alors c'était une situation n'y
avait plus d'entreprises pratiquement
équivalente en france d'une part et
d'autre part en terme de déficit de
balance des paiements sur ce produit
particulier les conséquences étaient
graves
le ministre de l'industrie s'en est
préoccupé
il se trouve que cette entreprise était
dans sa circonscription mêlant moi je
vais vous dire une chose
g j'étais dans une circonscription à
paris jusqu'à aux élections à la
proportionnelle
non je suis élu de paris en général si
j'avais une très très grosse entreprise
dans ma circonscription je me battrai
pour la défendre et je crois que si le
premier ministre ou le ministre de
l'industrie n'avait pas défendu
qu y compris chez lui une entreprise
dont l'intérêt était nationale même si
cela coûte cher on lui en aurait fait le
reproche
alors je crois qu'il a agit normalement
laurent fabius est un présidentiable ce
serait un bon candidat pour l'élection
présidentielle je crois déjà avoir fait
le tour de cette question mais vous
n'avez pas cité laurent fabius mais
parce qu'on ne m'a pas demandé alors
vous demande vous me demandez de quoi
alors à ma connaissance il y a une seule
personnalité socialiste jusqu'à
maintenant qui a évoqué le problème de
sa candidature on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est juste celle rocard je n'en
connais pas d'eau bien merci
jean marie colombani alors avant de
retourner asvp un sondage 1 télé sondage
sur la question que vous avez abordé
tout à l'oeil a dit là changement entre
la politique que pratiquée par monsieur
balladur et celle qui était pratiqué par
son prédécesseur monsieur bérégovoy le
sentiment des gens qui nous écoutent est
intéressant à connaître entre la
politique économique
si vous comparez la politique économique
d'avant mars et celle d'aujourd'hui
trouvez vous qu'il ya beaucoup de
différences 55% peu de différence c'est
quand même 35 % des personnes
interrogées qui trouve qu'il ya peu de
différences sans opinion 10%
voilà s&p oui monsieur j'apprends ici
encore il ya pour vous là ici
soir beaucoup de questions d'actualité
considérez vous que les contrôles
d'identité instaurée par le gouvernement
actuel soit véritablement une entrave à
la liberté
il faut il y à des pays d'abord je
voudrais dire qu'ils sont des pays
comparables au nôtre qui doivent
affronter aussi des problèmes
d'insécurité parfois même de terrorisme
je pense la grande-bretagne confronté à
la question irlandaise et où il n'existe
pas de papiers d'identité il faut quand
même que les français le sachent
nous avons des papiers d'identité j'ai
les miens sur moi et s'il le faut je les
montre c'est pas le problème
je pense que il ne faut pas que ces
mesures soient systématisées et enfin je
voudrais dire ça dépend aussi beaucoup
de l'état d'esprit dans lequel ces
contrôles éventuels sont opérés je pense
que les déclarations de monsieur pasqua
et monsieur pandraud tendant à dire nous
couvrirons la police ont eu un effet
désastreux et moi je voudrais dire que
autant je suis
après tout d'accord avec la formule
utilisée par monsieur pandraud je crois
il faut terroriser les terroristes mais
je ne pense pas qu'il faille terroriser
les honnêtes gens
or je constate que en raison de ses
paroles imprudentes
en quelques semaines se sont multipliées
plusieurs bavures graves
ce sont des enfants qu'on met au poste
qu'on met au dépôt sans prévenir les
parents se traitait à parillaud ça s'est
passé à paris aux vingt sept une
personne invalide à 100 % de 65 ans qui
est tabassé violemment par des policiers
c'est un jeune maghrébin qui réclame ses
papiers et qui se retrouvent esquinté
c'est un cadre à nouveau arrêtés et
molestés
alors le paradoxe dans cette affaire
c'est que ce gouvernement qui prétend
qu'il faut redonner du crédit à la
police alors que nous nous pensons que
la police elle avait tout à fait son
crédit sous l'autorité de pierre joxe et
bien il a d'une certaine façon réussi
cette prouesse quand quelques semaines
sans doute ou terroriser les terroristes
et je reconnais que c'est difficile il a
commencé finalement à faire en sorte que
des français aient peur de leur police
le résultat avouez le
est paradoxale jean-loup les scènes une
autre question
autre question d'actualité que pensez
vous de la réforme des loyers mise en
place par pierre méhaignerie la
suppression de la loi quillot nous
avions essayé de trouver un certain
équilibre entre les droits légitimes des
propriétaires et les droits des
locataires
je voudrais quand même rappeler que les
votes locataires sont 20 millions en
france je ne suis pas sûr qu'il faille
déséquilibré ce qui a été fait et je
craindrais que la flambée des loyers ou
la montée des loyers si ce n'était pas
contrôlée monsieur méhaignerie dit qu'il
y aura des mesures dans ce sens
aboutissent à déséquilibrer les choses
et à rendre plus difficile dans un
certain nombre de grandes villes
notamment à paris
le logement des personnes qui viennent
des milieux populaires
alors je sais que la proche de monsieur
et meigneux riz est relativement
prudente en tout cas qu'elle ne
satisfait pas les milieux qui sont
beaucoup plus à droite mais déjà comme
cela ça nous préoccupe un peu mais est
ce qu'à votre avis pendant la période
d'application de loquillo on a construit
suffisamment de logements ou moderniser
ce qui existait de france suffisante je
ne crois pas que la crise du logement
soit due à l'adoption de la loi quillot
ou alors c'est du partiellement à la
façon dont on a caricaturé la loi
quilliot mais la question est posée au
monde des entreprises en france
ne peut-on faire des logements ou ne
peut-on faire des bonnes affaires dans
quelques domaines que ce soit sans
revenir sur des législations existantes
en ad en ayant des législations - social
c'est ça le problème qui est posé
je pense que la crise du logement en
france vient d'une période bien
antérieure elle a commencé dans les
années 75 76
elle a été un peu la fin à la fois des
grandes spéculations sur la pierre qui
avait eu lieu qui n'avaient pas été
contrôlées par les gouvernements
conservateurs dans les années
précédentes
et puis petit trou aussi au fait que en
gros les grandes infrastructures et
l'essentiel des constructions étaient
étaient achevés fin je note que vous
êtes devenue critique très mesurée de la
loi méhaignerie
j'ai l'impression que monsieur
méhaignerie et critiqué assez
vigoureusement tout cas je lisais le
figaro ce matin par une fraction de la
majorité disons que je cède un instant à
une tentation tactique
bon eh bien pour un quart d'heure
maintenant albert du roy
j'espère bonsoir
cette tentation tactique est-ce que ça
et c'est ce jugement relativement
modérée puisque vous avez parlé d'
approche prudente de monsieur vignery
plan méhaignerie est ce que ça veut dire
que vous reconnaissez au sein du
gouvernement au sein de majorité
actuelle l'existence d'une tendance
centriste modéré à côté de tendance plus
conservatrice qui vous déplaisent
davantage il y a des oiseaux en cage
mais ouvrir ont-ils la porte de la cage
je ne sais pas et vente il ya quelques
éléments quelques éléments qui
visiblement on l'a vu par la rencontre
récente du cds qui n'approuvent pas tous
les aspects de la politique
gouvernementale en tout cas ses aspects
les plus ouvertement réactionnaire en
disant de de votre point de vue est ce
qui m est même monsieur séguin qui
pourtant très brutal à l'assemblée quand
ils nous répondent très véhément ses
dehors comme ça peu réformateur mais a
eu une phrase étonnante au club de la
presse je crois qu'il a fait
dernièrement en disant je m'efforce de
faire en sorte que ce gouvernement ne
soit pas celui de la revanche
ça c'est des cris du coeur mais lloris
méhaignerie ce gain est ce qu il yad
autres ministres qui de votre point de
vue vous plaisent gouvernement je n'ai
pas dit qu'il me plaisait en plus moi je
suis très normal si vous voulez donc
conçu par
préoccupé de savoir si monsieur mais
ignorer où se seguin me plaisent je n'ai
pas dit ça j'ai dit que sur quelques
questions
j'entendais des réactions qui n'était
pas extrêmement enthousiaste par exemple
sur l'autorisation administrative de
licenciement par exemple sur la
privatisation de tf1 bien ce sont je
pense à la fois d expression sincère et
peut-être aussi des fêlures mais ce ne
sont que des fêlures alors tout à
l'heure j'ai sursauté une phrase que
j'ai bien entendu le futur projet
socialiste vous le mettrez au point un
congrès qui aura lieu fin 87
vous pouvez par la foi me poser des
questions sur le temps et me chicaner
quand j'essaye de donner une réponse sur
le temps est d'accord mais je vous
demande vous avez dit ça ça sera
peut-être trois mois avant dans une
convention extraordinaire ça sera
peut-être mais le droit après je pense
qu'il me faudra un mois dans l'année 87
même trois mois avant je ne comprends
pas et vous me semblez d'une
inconscience sauf le métro d'inr puisque
vous aviez dit le 14 mars une majorité
rpr udf ne tiendrait pas six mois
moi oui n'avait jamais dit ça pendant la
campagne électorale
je ne crois pas en tout cas pas sous
cette forme brutale est catégorique ce
que je pense effectivement c'est que à
l'automne cette majorité aura rendez
vous avec elle même ou plutôt avec une
partie d'elle même et vous pensez
qu'elle révisait a été quand je lisais
l'article de monsieur l'interview de
monsieur millon proches de monsieur bart
bande de cette majorité dans libération
ce matin qui lui aussi disait que ce
gouvernement avait décidément un peu
trop un look réactionnaire et que disait
que c'était dommage je me dis que ce
sont des signes avant-coureurs je pense
que à l'automne
donc vous devez être prêt beaucoup plus
vite mais je ne dis pas que cela
provoquera nécessairement 7
ce choc ou cette conflagration que
qu'apparemment dons reçus potel à
supputer la date je ne dis pas ça je dis
que cette majorité aura des problèmes
vraisemblablement à l'automne plus
important qu'elle n'en a maintenant
c'est tout ce que je dis alors comme
comme les ce que ce que disait l'homme
politique totalement vous mais de toute
façon monsieur du roi j'ai cessé de
penser sur la base du travail que nous
avons fait pendant cinq ans qu'il faut
nécessairement que nous abordions la
prochaine période
avec un projet complet un programme
systématique sur tous les problèmes vous
êtes je pourrais aider vous êtes vacciné
contre les programmes
je pense qu'il est utile d'avoir des
références des grands axes qu'il faut
avoir une problématique une vision des
choses qu'il faut avoir peut-être un
certain nombre de propositions précises
si on croire raisonnablement qu'on peut
les atteindre et que pour le reste il
faut dire ce qu'on envisage de faire
croire que nous referons un programme
aussi pressante de l'avant fait là vous
vous rejoignez totalement le monsieur de
barriste monsieur millon que vous citiez
l'instant puisqu'il explique que ce qui
est très malheureux c'est que le
gouvernement s'emploie à réaliser point
par point le programme rpr udf
dans le cas précis c'est
particulièrement malheureux bientôt
bientôt tous les partis politiques
auront compris qu'il vaut mieux ne pas
faire des programmes 3d taille et parce
qu'on ne tient jamais c'est pas un
problème seulement de savoir si on fait
les programmes détaillés c'est le
problème de savoir quelles sont les
mesures qu'on préconise et je pense que
le programme du rpr et l'udf est un
programme effectivement qui est un
programme à la fois d'idéologues à
certains égards c'est le cas de la
privatisation de tf1 par exemple est un
programme surtout extrêmement anti
sociale extrêmement injuste est au fond
une des expériences que nous faisons
actuellement avec les difficultés de ce
gouvernement c'est que on disait
toujours oui la droite elle est un peu
injuste elle n'a pas suffisamment le
sens du progrès mais au moins elle sait
gérer alors qu'on constate qu'elle
revient aux affaires et qu'elle n'arrive
pas à bien gérer à bien gouverner et ça
c'est une chose formidable pour nous
pour l'avenir parce qu'au fond les
français nous ont sanctionnés parce
qu'on n'a pas réussi en tout mais ils
vont pouvoir se dire il n'y a pas de
malédiction à gauche la gauche a su
démontrer qu'elle savait gérer et la
droite c'est sous nos yeux
elle démontre qu'elle ne sait pas s'il
vient c'est simple et c'est pourquoi
c'est très important très important pour
l'avenir de notre pays pour les chances
gauche droite est pas exactement ce que
je mange que vous estimez que ce que
vous avez dit que le vous avez intérêt à
ce que la cohabitation dure comme ça les
français seront vaccinés contre la
droite c'est bien ça j'ai dit que les
français avaient fait un choix qu'il
fallait le respecter
je pense également que il est bon qu en
à l'échéance normale les français
effectivement ait pu confronter deux
politiques la politique de la gauche
la politique des socialistes pour être
plus clair et la politique de la ville
mais s'il si la politique de la droite
est tellement nuisible et vous expliquer
ce que sur bien des points elle est
nuisible
vous ne l'avez pas le droit de souhaiter
qu'elles durent longtemps
je sais stratégie du pire c'est
je ne vois pas en quoi je ne je pense
que le gouvernement chirac a un droit à
gouverner
je ne peux pas lui contester ce droit
nous menons au parlement une action très
clair sur le plan politique pour ne pas
lui faciliter l'application de sa
politique
si nous pouvons éviter un vote par
exemple sur l'autorisation
administrative de licenciement sur sa
suppression
nous en serons heureux si nous pouvons
accompagner la bataille de ceux qui ne
veulent pas la privatisation tf1 et
faire reculer le gouvernement sur ce
point qui constatera que c'est
décidément impossible de l'imposer aux
français nous en serons heureux fait
donc je n'emmène pas la politique du
pire mais sous prétexte que je ne mène
pas la politique du pire je n'ai pas le
droit de précipiter hâtivement les
échéances ni le droit ni le pouvoir vous
reparler au moins pour la deuxième ou
troisième fois et c'est vrai que c'est
au coeur des préoccupations des gens et
des débats actuels de la suppression de
300 me traiter de licenciement alors là
il ya quelque chose que je comprends pas
que vous allez m'expliquer il ya peu de
temps monsieur chirac que premier
ministre déjà sur ce plateau disait
expliqué que c'était un mythe mais qu'il
fallait passer par cette suppression de
l'autorisation administrative de
licenciement
c'était un mythe parce que ça n'avait
rien n'a jamais rien empêcher ça n'avait
jamais vraiment empêcher des
licenciements
la preuve d'ailleurs que c'est un mythe
ça n'a jamais empêché de licenciement
c'est que quand monsieur chirac premier
ministre en 74 l'avaient proposé les
socialistes avaient voté contre il
estimé que c'était une mesure totalement
insuffisante alors pourquoi est ce si ce
n'est tellement pas d'importance est ce
que tout le monde en fait une affaire
aussi importante y compris vous nous
avons voté contre en 1975 effectivement
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
nous souhaitions que conformément à ce
qui se passe dans d'autres pays en
europe la charge de la preuve en cas de
licenciement notamment devant les
tribunaux soit inversée que ce soit aux
chefs d'entreprises de montrer que le
licenciement était nécessaire il est
d'ailleurs mieux placé pour pouvoir le
faire
la deuxième raison pour laquelle nous
avons voté contre
c'est que nous disions si l'autorisation
administrative de licenciement n'est pas
accordé et que le licenciement est fait
quand même ce qui arrive parfois
alors nous considérons que le
licenciement ne peut pas s'appliquer que
les tribunaux doivent opérer la
réintégration ce qui n'était pas le cas
de la législation qui nous était proposé
qui proposait dans cette hypothèse
simplement des indemnités aux
travailleurs mais ceux qui ceux qui en
75 n'était qu'un gadget aujourd'hui
devient la forteresse qui protègent les
droits des salariés
personnellement je ne serais pas hostile
et je crois pas les socialistes à ce
qu'on recherche autre chose
je ne dis pas que c'est nécessairement
l'administration qui est forcément la
mieux placée pour dire si telle ou telle
de licenciement est nécessaire valeur à
condition qu'on trouve d'autres méthodes
et d'autres garde-fous c'est à dire par
exemple le garde-fou de la négociation
obligatoire avec les syndicats le
garde-fou de décision de tribunal qui
puisse se faire dans un sens favorable
aux salariés provoqué la réintégration
comme en france il n'ya pas ses
habitudes comme en france il n'y a pas
de stabilité des effectifs parce que
regarder quand même deux pays qui
luttent le mieux dans la bataille
économique c'est le japon le japon ont
les entreprises gagnent leurs effectifs
et pourtant ils sont compétitifs
l'allemagne le chef d'entreprise est
obligé de réintégrer
si le tribunal dit que le réintègre
amant est abusif et pourtant ils gagnent
dans la bataille économique
je ne pense pas que c'est en licenciant
nécessairement que l'on peut gagner la
bataille économique pour une entreprise
alors il ya autre chose que vous allez
m'expliquer c'est j'ai l'impression que
vous venez de faire un formidable cadeau
à monsieur pasqua
parce que le groupe parlementaire
socialiste a décidé que les députés
socialistes refuserait d'aller donner au
préfet de chaque département leur avis
sur les projets de découpage électoral
alors moi à la place de monsieur pasqua
je serais très content parce que je me
dirais maintenant je peux faire ce que
je veux et après quand on me reprochera
côté socialiste me reprocheront d'avoir
fait un découpage qui ne leur plaît pas
je pourrais leur dire mais vous n'aviez
qu'à faire vos suggestions elle aurait
évidemment été acceptée
si monsieur pasqua avait l'intention
nous faire des suggestions et qu'elle
soit à l'évidence accepté il y avait un
lieu idéal fait pour ça c'est le
parlement s'il nous avait présenté
clairement département par département
ou nouvelles circonscriptions par
nouvelles circonscriptions
ces suggestions avec une carte c'est est
ce que nous lui demandions avec des
critères nous aurions participé à la
consultation normale au parlement car
c'est quand même bien le moins que
l'assemblée vote son propre mode de
désignation
là c'est parce qu'on nous a proposé on
nous a proposé des conciliabules secret
l'assemblée vote par une procédure
rapide mais elle vote tel vote sans
connaître la carte sans connaître les
choses de façon précise et nous on vous
donne l'occasion de la voir et vous non
on nous donne
nous savons très bien que monsieur
pasqua a l'intention de faire ce qu'il
veut qu'il a déjà établi les
circonscriptions et cette carte dans ses
discussions avec monsieur gaudin et avec
les autres membres de l'udf et ce qu'ils
cherchaient à obtenir de nous et
éventuellement nous divisant dans tel ou
tel département
c'était une caution pour une procédure
dont nous pensons qu'elle n'est pas
démocratique
cette question devrait être débattue
normalement en détail et dans la
transparence à l'assemblée nationale
alors pris en commun dans les
explications et que vous êtes le patron
du parti socialiste comme les avantages
chez les socialistes qui parlent
beaucoup voudraient simplement prendre
deux trois déclarations ce que vous avez
à votre avis c'est dans un recto verso
du monde il ya quelques jours et il y en
a déjà un paquet là alors d'abord il ya
un article de jean françois trans qui
est un assemblage de quatre ou cinq
militants qui grosso modo répond un peu
haut à l'article que vous aviez écrit et
qui se termine par cette phrase savoir
ce que vous en pensez
quand tout le monde est moderne c'est le
signe qu'il faut inventer autre chose
moderne est un mot terne alors il me
semble que dans votre article
il y avait une espèce de plaidoyer pour
le modernisme mais un modernisme un peu
plus brillant que terne à dire que le
modernisme n'est pas terne
je pense que c'est une discussion sur
des mots dessus pas sûr qu'elle soit
très très très clair je pense que le
parti socialiste est un parti vivant
c'est un outil pour moi un outil ouvert
c'est un instrument que ce
donnez des hommes et des femmes que
reconnaissent les français par leur vote
pour essayer de faire à la fois de la
démocratie et de l'action politique et
je pense que ce parti s'il est un
organisme vivant
il doit s'adapter à une réalité qui
changent comme un organisme vivant
sinon les organismes vivants qui ne
s'adaptent pas meurs voilà ma vision de
la modernité
elle est toute simple et je pense que je
dois la partager avec ses 4 ou 105
personnes que vous avez été retrouvé à
la loupe et non par la loupe c'est un
grand article v cap colonnes dans le
monde en plus c'est très bien que vous
ayez éprouvé le besoin de prendre
l'opinion de quatre ou cinq militants du
vernis social mais c'est pas moi c'est
eux qui ont pris l'initiative mais je
dis pas ce que je vous ai devant moi et
je demande est encore des explications
la rhk car il dit qu'il incarne un
longue efforts pour enlever ses
béquilles ou ses menottes au socialisme
et il combine continue être socialiste
et rocardien c'est la même chose
alors est ce que vous êtes rocardien
être rocardien et socialistes c'est la
même chose
voilà l'ordre dans lesquels je donne les
choses je suis socialiste je suis
d'abord un homme tout simplement je ne
suis pas né socialiste même si je suis
né dans une famille socialiste
je suis un homme tue un homme de mon
temps et il se trouve que je suis
socialiste oui parce que je crois que
c'est un ensemble de références de
valeur d'actions pratique très
importante pour un pays moderne comme le
nôtre et le parti socialiste enlever ses
béquilles et ses menottes au les
menottes c'est de l'autre côté
caricatural du socialisme qu'on appelle
d'ailleurs plus justement
malheureusement maintenant le communisme
et quant aux béquilles oui je pense que
on en a enlevé quelques unes
effectivement c'est pas c'est pas dans
ceux dans cette liste là mais monsieur
qu'il est ce qu'ils étaient
membre important du parti socialiste un
jour parler il récemment il a dit qu'il
fallait dépoussiérer le vocabulaire
socialiste
le seul mot auquel vous voulez pas
touché c'est le mot socialiste parce que
vous venez de rappeler qu'il était
utilisé pour les pays de l'est
il est utilisé il était aussi utilisé
par les nazis national socialisme c'est
un mot qui a une histoire lourde à
porter je pense que vous risquez
d'influencé de façon négative les gens
qui vous écoute je pourrais vous dire
que le libéralisme
c'était la politique économique de
monsieur videla c'est à dire de la
dictature argentine
et c'est en ce sens que vous critiquez
le libéralisme mais je crois que le
socialiste pour lequel nous nous sommes
battus à différentes époques de notre
vie c'est toujours en ce qui nous
concerne on le sait bien
confondue avec la liberté avec la
création avec la recherche de
l'épanouissement individuel et donc on
sait très bien que les menottes
elles ne sont pas de notre côté on les a
parfois à passer par contre aux mains de
nos anciens mais comment se fait il que
le mémo vous soyez attaché à ce mot qui
traduit des réalités tellement
différente et dont certaines
particulièrement odieuse je crois que ce
qu'on appelle les pays socialistes
appartiennent en réalité au monde
communiste
et je pense que c'est le mot communiste
ou parfois le mot stalinien qui a ré qui
répondent de ce qu'a été leur histoire
et de ce qu'elle est en réalité en rien
je crois le socialisme dans nos pays ne
peut se rapprocher de ce modèle il ne se
confond qu'avec la liberté alors mettre
ma dernière citation de la série là
c'est monsieur georges sarre qui est
député socialiste et qui dit quand je je
je raccourcis je résume quand nous
verrons pouvoir il faudra procéder à de
nouvelles nationalisations
c'est ce sera dans le programme
socialiste sait pas exactement ce qu'il
a dit moi aussi je lis attentivement les
les écritures ou les articles de
mercerie nous nationalisons les groupes
industriels et les banques qui seront
nécessaires pour une politique
industrielle volontariste ne seront pas
mécaniquement les mêmes voilà il n'a pas
dit qu'il faudrait de nouvelles
nationalisations il a dit qu'il ne faut
pas s'imaginer que le gouvernement
actuel puisse privatiser toute une série
d'entreprises notamment des entreprises
qui étaient publics depuis 1945 et
penser que cela sera éternelle c'est ce
qu'a dit georges sarre c'est une idée de
bon sens en tout cas nous agissons nous
agirons
ce domaine avec la même vision qui était
la nôtre à savoir en faire un outil de
progrès économique
le mettre au service d'une politique
industrielle pas d'une idéologie
peut-être aussi d'une certaine
amélioration des rapports sociaux dans
l'entreprise
une dernière question personnelle je
veux pas vous demandez pas ce que vous
avez déjà répondu ou plutôt n'est pas
répondu sur vos intentions à l'égard de
l'elysée mais on dit souvent deux
excellentes on veut on dit souvent de
vous que votre popularité vient de ce
que vous êtes ou vous êtes beaucoup
d'ambitions pour votre parti pour vos
idées c'est évident personne ne conteste
mais que vous êtes dépourvu d'ambitions
personnelles
est ce que c'est vrai je pense que
l'ambition d'un homme en tout cas en
politique je dis pas que c'est forcément
pareil pour un créateur mais l'ambition
d'un homme ou d'une femme en politique
n'a de sens que si elle se confond
s'identifie avec une ambition plus
collective avec une aspiration plus
vaste je crois cela profondément et par
ailleurs je suis sûr que dans la
situation politique actuelle y compris
au sein du parti socialiste avec ses
diversités que vous évoquez à l'aide de
quelques articles de journaux j'ai un
rôle irremplaçable à jouer pour que tout
le monde se rassemble pour que ces
destins individuels s'inscrit dans une
perspective d'ensemble ce rôle j'ai bien
l'intention de le jouer parce que
finalement personne d'autre que moi ne
peut le chef de l'opposition c'est vous
si vous voulez dire que je dois aussi
remplir le rôle de georges marchais ça
c'est une distribution à laquelle je ne
prétend pas bien albert du roy vous
restez avec nous nous allons à vendre
avant d'aller à la sofres pour terminer
cette émission voir avec jérôme jaffré
comment vous avez été reçu ce soir deux
dernières questions asvp
question d'actualité encore que
pensez-vous du limogeage de claude qu'un
le patron communiste de la ratp
je veux pas me mêler des choix du
gouvernement
je voudrais simplement dire deux choses
premièrement la situation de la ratp
était bonne bonne image augmentation du
trafic augmentation de la productivité
situation financière qui ne s'était
nullement dégrade et donc quelles sont
les raisons de fond deuxième remarque je
trouve que pour un gouvernement qui se
pique de libéralisme ce comportement à
l'égard d'une entreprise autonome la
régie autonome des transports parisiens
ce nous paraît pas très libérale bien
une dernière question aujourd'hui le 7e
art
une second une seconde parce que je
crois qu'elle vient du roi veut réagir
alors une dernière question j'avais 7 2
si vous le permettez comment se fait-il
que le ps n'organise pas de
manifestations massives pour réagir
contre le nouveau projet de la droite
nous sommes présents au parlement sur
plusieurs projets par exemple les
licenciements nous allons mener une
action plus massive
je veux dire par là par exemple que nous
avons un tract qui sera diffusé un
million d'exemplaires nos élus nos
parlementaires iront portes des
entreprises feront des conférences de
presse et crieront comité d'entreprise
pour mener cette action dans le pays nos
militants nos adhérents le ferons aussi
mais les organisations
mais les masses les manifestations de
masse ça ne se décrète pas nous
prendrons notre part des mouvements qui
se manifesteront notre juste part
dernière question plus personnelle on
vous fait amateur de football
quel est votre pronostic pour le mondial
en ce qui concerne l'équipe de france
eh bien il faudra qu'elles tiennent
mieux la balle notamment au milieu de
terrain
si elle veut aller plus loin je pense
qu'elle sortira de sa poule
ça sera dur demain conclure ce elle sera
qualifiée j'espère je pense pour les
huitièmes après ça sera un problème de
fraîcheur et garder la balle au sol
pendant que pendant que
pendant que vous parliez il ya un match
qui se déroulait c'était le match rfa
uruguay et votre pronostic sur ce match
puisque vous n'en connaissez pas le
résultat
à défaut de me mettre en défaut en
matière de pronostics sur la co
existence institutionnelle vous essayez
de me piéger au football allemagne
uruguay
l'allemagne a gagné non vous auriez vu
fait de garder votre pronostic de tout à
l'heure vous aviez dix matches nuls
j'avais dit match nul ou victoire pour
laisser finalement une surprise c'est
match nul 1 partout bien alors nous
allons maintenant savoir nous allons le
verdict de cette soirée est ce que vous
avez est-ce que vous avez convaincu es
ce que vous avez fait changer les gens
d'avis pendant l'émission
eh bien j'appelle jérôme jaffré
directeur des études politiques de la
sofres bien comme on le constate
habituellement mesure monsieur jospin a
tiré son épingle du jeu ce soir mais je
dirais que la performance personnelle a
été très réussi la performance politique
en revanche est plus controversé
alors tout d'abord at on une bonne
opinion de monsieur jospin
nous avons posé la question juste au
tout début de l'émission et nous l'avons
posée à la fin
et là on constate une progression très
sensible des bonnes opinions
ce qui est intéressant c'est que par
rapport à l'émission précédente de
monsieur jospin du 19 février
on retrouve pratiquement les mêmes
pourcentages et la même progression en
cours d'émission pour monsieur jospin
deuxième série de questions monsieur
jospin at il été convaincant là il était
trop tard pour introduire le mundial
nous sommes donc restés sur des
questions politiques
est ce qu il a été convaincant sur le
rôle de françois mitterrand sur les
critiques à l'égard des mesures du
gouvernement
et enfin sur les moyens de reconquérir
le pouvoir pour le ps alors je dirais
que sur le pré carré de la gauche
le rôle de monsieur mitterrand en
particulier on voit une très nette
majorité de convaincant ce qui montre
que finalement une autre question le
montrer dans l'émission la position des
socialistes dans cette période de la
cohabitation est bien comprise sur les
critiques à l'égard du gouvernement
c'est beaucoup plus controversée à
l'image politique du pays sur les moyens
pour le ps de reconquérir le pouvoir le
débat introduit par jean marie colombani
tout à l'heure là on voit une majorité
négative
sans doute parce que monsieur jospin a
déclaré qu'il avait plus encore de
questions que de réponses sur ce point
et dernière série de questions est ce
qu'on souhaite que le parti socialiste
reviennent rapidement
au pouvoir où il reste longtemps dans
l'opposition nous avons posé la question
juste au début de l'émission est juste à
la fin et nous avons une majorité
négative au début comme à la fin même
très légèrement plus creusé en fin
d'émission au début sans doute parce que
monsieur jospin n'a pas apporté toutes
les réponses à la façon dont le ps
pourrait revenir au pouvoir et la
dernière question est également
intéressante de ce point de vue est ce
que le parti socialiste doit se
moderniser
où est ce qu'ils n'en a pas besoin la
réponse là est très nette 49% pensent
qu'il doit se moderniser 18% seulement
qu'il n'en a pas besoin
parmi les sympathisants de gauche le
souhait de la modernisation du parti
socialiste monte à 53 %
voilà et bien une dernière une dernière
précision qui vient confirmer ce que
vient de dire jean loup le cndp monsieur
claude cas des pêches de 21h54 monsieur
claude cas présent de la ratp annoncé
mercredi soir à l'issue de l'entretien
avec monsieur joffrin de fiac qu'il
avait remis à celui ci cette démission
de la présidence de la ratp et de membre
du conseil d'administration voilà
c'était l'heure de vérité de monsieur
lionel josse pâte prochaine invitée le 2
juillet monsieur charles pasqua
bonsoir
[Musique]